yes we did cuz we back at it again it's
the fighter in the kid this is really
the fighter in the kid come on baby it's
stuff your ass Thursday well chin was
chin we were just having a conversation
and uh chin said do we leave this in
what what I was talking about was that I
sent my wife uh if I'm on Instagram
which I should never be I'm scrolling
through and I'll see some very athletic
beautiful man sometimes black sometimes
Latin sometimes White she's opportunity
okay if she had a business she would
probably hire blacks first because she
loves black people and um uh and I uh I
will send her a picture of some uh
beautiful black man sprinting and I'll
just say something like [__] haha it's a
joke yeah the problem is the algorithm
now thinks I'm into black men who are
very muscular and they're right started
sending me now now every time I scroll
I'm like there's another gorgeous black
man and now it's sending me maybe like
gorgeous white dudes with tattoos on
their necks and I'm and then I Linger on
the picture it's it's feel the algorithm
is feeling out it's like all right so we
know you're into black here's a white
yes and that and then I linger like this
guy likes it all what about Latino and
I'm all about La it's not sending you
which says a Lin no hot Asians you piece
of [__] you know what you know what
you're right about that I but I just I
Linger on it here's the problem here's
the problem now it's sending me now it's
nudging me it's just going like it sent
me a picture of a dude who had a towel
he had a towel and you could see his
impossible piece pushing the towel yeah
and I went what's taking you down the
road push you slow into only fans yeah
and I had to say that to I had to say
that to my girl I said I went good
morning and now the algor is like this
guy likes even bigger and now now let's
remove the towel next thing you know
you're just looking at gay porn well
yesterday I at your age you come up the
closet yesterday I knew I was the
algorithm believes I'm gay the algorithm
truly believes I'm gay because yesterday
there was a Instagram thing where I see
a guy good-looking guy at a table and
he's going you're not paying attention
and that's the problem and when you
don't pay attention I get angry and I
feel like I'm wasting my time then you
hear a guy's voice go yeah well why
should I listen to you he goes why
should you listen to me and he gets up
out of the T he gets off from the
teacher's chair and oh he's got a pair
of white khakis that are too tight with
an impossible bone and he goes what are
you do with that ruler and I go godamn
it here but I watched it now the
algorithm is like this guy likes
watching that you're a gay man the alth
does lie the algorithm doesn't lie does
it because algorithm AI figured out that
like this what he likes I'm closet I'm
semi I'm closeted I'm a closet mine's
all trucks and mods and yours all gay
men that's the difference between us
that's got to be nice for your wife I
mean at least your algorithm isn't a
bunch of hot chicks that's true no
interest in hot chicks no interest I'm
like whatever oh look tits whatever oh
guy you know yeah yeah I know it's a
problem hey did you uh just quick
question brain did you suck any [__] in
Cal I'm glad you asked I didn't I didn't
do that but I did go to an MMA gym s
alanka in Sak which is an interesting
thing I didn't know but I hit mits now
here's the thing at 56 Baba when I go to
a gym to hit mits you know old Bri isn't
GNA you know warm up I'm just going to
go crazy CU I want people to think I can
hit Ms yeah and uh my body's little
little calcified right now A little sore
the mustache slows down 10% a little bit
buddy a little bit everybody in Calgary
mustache cuz it's movember oh or or
everybody mustache is Calgary Calgary
and Calgary is you know the Texas the
Alberta is the Texas of Canada all the
everybody up and they're all pretty
conservative my boy Brad I did Brad
Forte open on Thursday he's great he's
great right yeah and and he's such a
nice dude is there a nicer person on the
planet best such a good guy and funny as
[__] so funny uh crushing it and um but
uh design at Denver designed around
Denver really yep it looks just like
Denver yep same designer like architect
for Denver did calg it's also very high
up not quite as high as Denver but it's
very high and also super dry and I was
like why am I why do I have no strength
when I'm lifting weights here and I was
like oh it's my bone structure no it's
not you know I just had no water in my
body you know who's the mayor of Calgary
is uh Brett Hart his family lives like
up on the hill Oh really y it's a great
City now now cold yeah now here's the
thing yeah December is cold well it so
November this was the first time where I
was able to walk around and I had uh I
had only three layers on but if you're a
calgarian that you know it's it's 38 40°
they're like flip flops they're in
[__] short sleeve shirts and shorts
and I'm not kidding and you're like how
the [__] but it gets down to 40 below
ladies and gentlemen well that's why
it's all like it's like it's inside it's
like Edmonton you know how the malls and
the offices it's all indoor yes like the
streets can just there's indoor just
Pathways everywhere everybody's coming
from British Columbia from Quebec from
the different provinces that are super
super liberal and they're moving they're
coming over to Calgary Alberta less
taxes you know more freedom thanks
Castro yeah right um you know what
though if you want to go hunting you go
out to Calgary you'll see a lot of
people come through
with camo cuz there's nothing but bear
giant cougars well outside Toronto and
Montreal it's pretty blue collar yeah
Vancouver but those major cities but
like Calgary even Calgary is like blue
collar Rich it's it's collar yeah man
crazy money like like you don't realize
how much money is there CU it's oil but
you you want some you want a cat you
want a bag a 200 PB wolf Alberta you
want to bag a polar bar Alberta kill a
Native American Alberta no no no no it's
no it's their first nation what First
Nation People First Nation big people
according to you big people according to
you by the way big people my books are
different when you get to the cold
regions people have the people put on
some weight they big people up there
they a insulate yeah this the food and
sunshine yeah they're thick they're
about as white some of the people are
about as white as that screen yeah so
that screen's a little tanner than some
of the calgarians rightfully so yeah but
it's a great town what are you doing for
Thanksgiving buddy since you have seven
families very good question and I'm glad
you asked that so here's the thing about
Thanksgiving I yeah great yeah you've
been thinking about it oh yeah seven
turkeys well what happens is I love my
wife but but women in my family live for
these holidays white women they live for
it Whit oh is that true wh not I love
Thanksgiving oh cuz it's American I'm
not white no it's American Mexicans
aren't oh yeah what are you doing for
Thanksgiving this is the first year I'm
not cooking just saying first year
though white people don't miss no no no
Thanksgiving it's a thing big thing so
now we got flower arrangements we got
napkins but here's the thing you if you
start inviting
people but we don't have enough room we
got it's going to be 12 inviting family
well family because my kids my kids my
my rest of my family is all in New York
well I was supposed to go to my cousins
in Stanford Conneticut the problem with
that Bubba is I got to take my kids to
New York and then drive to Stanford rent
a car just that's just the sound of not
happening I went as much as you travel
not happening I said I can't do it they
should come to you as much as you travel
and you have the kids you have the small
kids and my my other kids so I'm keeping
my kids at my house all my kids I'll be
there and then we're going to we invited
a couple but then what happens is there
are Strays that you want to bring in no
there's not there's no room there's no
room Strays there's no room there's no
Strays yeah say no no no no no yeah it's
about family yeah I mean there's the
friends giving you can do that but at 50
family my family knows I don't we travel
so much for work outside that I got the
kids it's way harder for me to travel
than you if you want holidays I'm here
outside that you and I you and I get
offered lots of nice trips we could go
on all the time you know we could go on
some we could go anywhere we wanted for
free and uh Capital black.com can't do
it what what' you say you want to go to
black.com I don't know I've never heard
of black.com go to black.com and let's
see what no don't go that let's just
talking about well no we just got a new
computer well that's why his other one
burnt down cuz you're stupid gay hey
search Kabachi black I don't know what I
don't know what I don't know what
black.com I know that Kanye West said he
liked it but I don't know what it is you
don't want to go
there see the the problem is uh white
people love Thanksgiving Mexicans no
it's not a Mexican holiday but they they
Christmas though Christmas now oh we we
had the tree up a month ago yes I I post
a picture on Instagram story my kids
came down and uh Christmas Jamies Go
Bubba it's not even Thanksgiving what
are you guys doing yes said Mom gave it
to us like Jesus Christ my my my wife
same thing Thanksgiving is the appetizer
it's the rev up um it's the it's the
it's how you rev your engine for
Christmas so we already have the tree
Halloween Thanksgiving and Christmas
whites go
crazy yeah my girl goes nuts for
Christmas Latina's Christmas and then
Thanksgiving I had to put my my goddamn
American foot down say need some turkey
mashed potatoes up in this [__] I'm
sick of the pole I'm not eating soup for
Thanksgiving we're not communist so we
have turkey stuffing cranberry juice
yeah sauce too I uh I wouldn't mind
having a different kind of fowl this
Thanksgiving so lame who decided to make
that ugly [__] you ever seen a turkey in
person they're hideous how about a
pheasant how about a couple pheasant in
a duck that sounds delicious lame too
[__] all birds yeah yeah I hate birds
man you ever have pheasant no man I'm
not rich
a I shot fee out of the sky by the
dozens and then I how about we have some
uh Rats of the sky some pigeons deep
fried pigeons I've had there's nothing
like it's I think it's called squab I've
had it in France I ate a head you know I
ate a pigeon head I know they put a
napkin in front of you and you take it
by the beak and you go no and he's alive
no yeah it's a tradition it's a
tradition they used to take these little
birds that you they drown in brandy then
they cook them and you eat the whole
bird but that's I'm fancy [__] Shen go
back squab is good [__] for the rich go
back squab you see that domestic pigeon
I'm talking about that that Woodland
Hills hitter he's going to have some
plutons in his body rock dubs and rock
pigeons are the same you got wood
pigeons that [__] is all delicious man
if I'm homeless I set up so many pigeon
traps yeah yes you do eat them dude
thank you cook them on the fire yet open
fire some pigeons some Rats of the sky
100% be let's take a little break we're
getting hot and juicy today cuz we're
thinking of turkeys it's just Brien Bri
scho old school it's the kid and the we
need anybody buddy we sure don't it's
just the two of us just the two of
us just the two of us we can make it if
we TR the two of us I like watching the
NL and I Chicago December 8th and 9th
I'll be in Chicago buddy eating deep
dish pizza December 789 I'll be in
Indiana at Helium Comedy Club hell yeah
dude you
that one go I ripped it didn't I I
ripped my shorts I ripped my pants but
I'll tell you what man it's turkey
season that means football on
Thanksgiving got the Dallas Cowboys you
got Green Bay you got Detroit Lions are
popping right now and you can eat turkey
that stupid dry bird and make money
watching the NFL with DraftKings you new
customers can bet just five bucks on the
NFL action to score 150 instantly and
bonus bets no matter your appetite
there's something for you money lines
parlays props live bets and so much more
you name it they got it so download the
draft game Sports wi app right now use
the code fighter new customers can bet
five on the NFL Thanksgiving action to
score 150 instantly in bonus bets only
on draft te Sportsbook and official
sports betting partner the NFL with the
code Fighter the crown is yours gambling
problem call 1800 gambling in New York
call 8778 hope Andy or text Hope NY 467
369 in West Virginia visit www.8 00
gambler. net please play responsibly in
Connecticut help is available for
problem gambling call 888 78977 77 or
visit ccpg dog or on behalf of booill
Casino and Resort KS must be 21 or older
in most eligible States but age varies
by jurisdiction see draftkings.com
Sportsbook for details and state
specific responsible gambling resources
eligibility and deposit restrictions
apply bonus bets expire 168 hours after
issuance terms at Sports book.
draftkings.com
terms hey B get off your phone dude
because I'm about to drop some news on
your old ass what tell me tell Dude I
know you like old school stuff how about
you invest in some silver some gold like
Scrooge McDuck dude you got to diversify
your financial portfolio dude with
everything going on war inflation the E
the economy there's a lot going on man
so I'm just yeah here's thing nobody's
ever said nobody ever said oh you want
this bar of gold nobody ever was like
nah it's not worth anything in the
history of the world dude I've collected
so much gold and silver I tried jumping
in it like Scrooge McDuck broke my neck
a cartoon do goldco go to goldco all
right.com right now let me explain
something to you they got rated A+ by
the Better Business Bureau they've
earned over 5,000 festar reviews they're
a seven time Inc 5000 winner I don't
know what that means but it sounds
pretty awesome dude and right now the
fin kid listeners and viewers they're
offering you guys up to $10,000 in bonus
silver while the supplies glass go to
goldco that's
g.com fighter to learn more I'm talking
about that domestic New York manhatt
nothing like a good bird when it's
roasted over an open fire when we're in
the field you know what I'm saying bro I
would like to switch up Thanksgiving
just do
steak I I I'm a I'm a game I don't get
enough game meat in my diet and I need
to start that rich [__] dude I'm talking
about pizza I got to go I got my mom did
Pizza on Christmas I'm trying to I'm
trying to go goose hunting and spaan
when I go there [__] you yeah I want to
go goose hunting and shoot it oh how
tough is that no here's my idea bro
those little white those big white birds
I want to shoot a goose fast and then I
want to I want to I want to take it to a
good restaurant in spaan or somewhere
around there a great restaurant and have
the chef prepare it for me stuff it I
want a stuffed
Goose I want some stuffed Goose feather
it yourself oh I'll pluck it take all
night yeah it takes a long time to pluck
that b the feathers take forever to
pluck yeah make I've never done it but I
can only imine make your forearm sore
the next day why are your forearms sore
pluck the pluck the goose pluck it you
got to pluck a goose hey stuffed
Christmas goose is great you're supposed
to have a stuffed Goose for Christmas
I'd love a goose yeah you got to mix it
up cuz some people do turkey on
Thanksgiving on a Christmas too what's
the Christmas isn't it ham ham yeah [__]
ham I hate Pig a never hadala I hate Pig
Yeah a never had that also it's also uh
also Jews don't eat pig it's in I might
be it's in the Old Testament really yeah
yeah I don't I don't mess with any por
it's in the Book of Leviticus praise
nothing with a clo musim either Muslims
no Pig no the only thing I like is
pepperoni but you can get all beef
pepperoni uh I like I love Pig bacon
I'll eat I'll eat bacon I want die by
eating bacon choose one way to die I'd
be like I'll eat keep doing it give me
all the B keep doing it then not good
for you right literally the worst thing
you put in your body is that is that
true yep I don't let my son eat it
anymore he loves bacon not anymore [__]
causes cancer or something oh yeah it's
so toxic is it so toxic could be a worst
thing for you that's why it's so tasty
it's so tasty name something that tasty
that's good for you well see um Daddy
doesn't eat uh when I eat bread I get
like my tummy gets all bloated so I
don't eat bread anymore I just eat
vegetables and meat and stay tight I
stay I keep it tight bro oh boy you have
[__] ponia you have pneumonia my
cousin canell her Thanksgiving cuz she
in Denver My Brother Jay and my mama
always go over her house Bridges she got
Co really sent that to the family group
chat and I put you mean you have a cold
and that did not go well yeah yeah I
love that yep cuz you have Co he cold
yeah now days CO's a cold in 2023 you
got cold yeah I said who gets Co in 202
didn't go over well no didn't go over
well there's a reason I don't get
invitations anymore yeah difficult as
they say yeah what do you uh what's your
uh do you stick to a diet are you still
carnivore still carnivore yep and what
do you have though do what do you have
any kind of vegetables or
fruit just depends sometimes I'll have
mix in some corn some
spinach which isn't very carnivore but
if it's there and I need a little more
calories I'll do it but I've been
carnivore for weeks now and then what do
you do uh supplementation wise do you
take supplements lot of [__] lot of [__]
do you you drink your coffee gotta have
your coffee I have to now do you uh do
you take so no fruit no nothing you a
little sweetie you're a little sweetie
no cuz my teeth at night ever since I
saw the dentist I haven't touched sweets
I don't touch them that's why I've lost
so much weight I don't touch sweets
anymore yeah what are you wearing right
the only thing I can eat is Twizzlers
cuz they don't stick to my teeth so you
eat your twizz you'll see some Twizzlers
in the car not at night but in the car
you got some twizzies
twizz like the most thing of the sixe
teeth no no it's not cuz it's covered in
a wax it's uh it's Red Vines with the
sticky Twizzlers don't stick twiz I
would know and what about chocolate
chocolate guy you a chocolate definitely
can't eat chocolate you can't oh that
gets in the root of your teeth blah oh
and it hurts dude you ever going to get
your teeth fixed you just going let yeah
I'm just going to let them go until
you're so it's till it's a real problem
no you be in biggest braces braces yeah
I'm 40 you're like invis I'm like who am
I doing it for for yourself so you can
fix your bite it only gets worse oh no
oh no your teeth are all cracked with
holes dude oh no hey dude come on it's
your teeth bro when you're 56 you're
going to be like I can't even I got to
let me take this out can I do I have to
cheer this this should go all
vene really yeah easy work file them
down put the caps on Daddy damn bro Jes
damn damn damn damn cuz you do that and
then next you're doing your Lids you're
doing your nose you're doing your
tits well I I H yeah wouldn't mind
tightening the old face up a little look
at how good watch this look at this [__]
see I don't think you need any of that I
think you should go to Turkey I think
you should go to Turkey what do you
think go to Turkey that's yeah I don't
think I don't think turkey works because
I don't think I have enough hair to pull
back but look at this ask the experts
dude are you [__] kidding me right
now you don't think I look amazing
seriously look at how wide
my you ever do anything with your face
I've had my nose done I'm Persian every
girl has yeah it's like it's like your
that's your sweet 16 as a nose dude my
mom told me at at a young age it's ugly
we're going to fix it you came out you
came out with a beak huge Persian women
are beautiful well I think so bless your
heart I think Middle Eastern women are
gorgeous some of them Brian just like
any culture some of the best looking
women I've i' I yeah I've seen some foul
ones too
dude I've seen some I've seen some
warlocks I've seen some dimes Jordan
yeah name a place dude there's some
hotties and there's also some fatties
world are you I didn't see I only saw I
only see beauty dude I uh got these new
boots sorry too much hum got these new
boots gonna get the brown ones uh shoot
the bear they're called oops gave my
secret away [__] now everybody's
going to buy them see here's the thing
dude um you're going to see me in Boots
from now on I'm an adult now done with
my sneakers well you you do this you go
back and forth back and forth yeah a
little bit of a Fickle fickle fickle
yeah I mean those work for now those
work for you yeah just kind of simple
boots just hanging Geor what are you
doing for
Thanksgiving I don't have any than
specific planned um you guys want to
take an as
stray well I told you I don't do that
but Brian well we don't have
room and uh take you and yours I've got
to take in about four other Strays I've
known way longer than you so here's what
I want you to do I want you to go to a
gas station get yourself a baked potato
no piece some in a processed turkey roll
and eat it in the [__] bathroom in
the corner while you cry no here's the
here's the move George I've done this
too when I was in the UFC when I would
be in Camp I wouldn't go around my
family Chinese places are open on
American holidays oh that's not Chinese
and Jewish that's not depressing at all
oh you're by yourself eating sweet and
sour chicken Chinese chines plac is in a
mini mall get yourself some fried rice
and some with some of that spam or
whatever the fck you spend Thanksgiving
Christmas at Panda Express go to the
airport in fact take a shuttle of the
airport and go to Panda Express and get
yourself a a styrofoam plate but you're
going to see the fam Chicago when I'm
out there you going the same time
December 8th and 9th mhm you bringing
the fam to the shows yeah as long as my
dad can cuz he has to get a surgery
right beforehand so he might be now
George if you said Brian can you fly me
to Chicago I would do that a well for
Thanksgiving I already bought my ticket
reimburse no for Thanksgiving for
Thanksgiving also that's what Brian's
offering right now that's so sweet that
is sweet I don't think you like that
ticket price that's very
sweet he didn't say what say I didn't
say you just said I said I'll get you a
bus it's going to take seven days to get
there and you have a stop and El Paso we
get you there chin bring up look how
much tickets are up tickets from LA to
Chicago right now start with spirit
I not I'm not going to fly you this
Thanksgiving we'll book it for next year
no if you really want to go I mean
a I I'll
contribute round trip from 162 that's on
Spirit no I'll F I'll say it's perfectly
fine you have to leave Spirit you got to
pay for
water tomorrow right no you going have
to leave tomorrow Sun uh thanksgiving's
on Thursday so leave Wednesday no for
real I don't care about the price Sor if
you really want I I will fly you yeah
price isn't an issue for Brian
yeah spirit for 162 United 378 that's
not bad no no we'll just uh I'll cover
your Wi-Fi yeah yeah wait what I got his
Wi-Fi hey that's hey you can't just you
don't want him to fly without any
entertainment fine I'll load up some
movies on your iPad yep uh yeah let me
know if you want to sweet thank you I'll
pay for half of it Georgie you want to
go hav oh now you want to come in well
I'll go havy I don't want you can't fire
the K send you how's that sound yeah
there you go that's havies yeah it's
havies that's really sweet guys of
course I'll tell we don't do enough we
don't do enough for our for chin and
Georgy really or youas so give them some
of your money I'm going give them some
of your salary take off oh man sucks no
no you're feeling so generous take 20%
of yours like a lot you're you're the
guy here you know what I've been
practicing
non-attachment take 50% there is this
I've been reading about vidon which is
like this like it's like U it's like
Buddhism or whatever and the the Swami
this famous famous swanie who's really
Western educated but like really famous
guy and he was like uh Hey guys can you
not uh when I say practice Detachment
and giving don't sell all your stuff
give all your money away and then show
up my ashram cuz a lot of these
westerners are like I'm in I'm all in
take everything and then they're like I
don't have any money and he's like I
don't have any [__] for don't do that
I'm not saying that stop doing that it's
a mindset I'm not saying sell your
[__] house idiot and give the money
to charity so hilarious what do you got
Jen so so are we sending Georgie to uh
Chicago you want to go Georgie look it
now if we want yeah I'm if you want for
real just yeah just tell cover Georgie
we don't want you hear crying at pen to
fly to Chicago and then what do you do
uh then I'll yeah one of my family
members pick me up here's the kicker so
the flights going to go from from LA to
Albuquerque to El Paso up to Chicago
you'll make it on time just in time it
won't be direct you're not going to
let's not get crazy man we're on a
budget here and then you're going to go
from Chicago to London and back and have
another stop in Al Albuquerque that's it
that's we'll get you there that's right
we'll get you there I think that's sweet
of course it's it's super
sweet you want to go really looking on
Expedia you want to go Tuesday or
Wednesday
Georgie wait we're talking about
Thanksgiving or what we talking about
Thanksgiving man that means yeah he's
got to work Wednesday yeah so we'll say
Wednesday nights do we n do we oh are we
are we are we is fighter and the kid
closed
Wednesday so the cheapest is I'm going
be here anyway I'm gonna be here anyway
Wednesday I can come out check Skys
scanner the cheapest
680 what's the Greyhound bus no look at
my face what happened to the prices
there yeah we saw one for 180 CH what
happened that was okay it it
automatically selected December so I I
punched in tomorrow or Wednesday till
Sunday little like notice that's the
cheapest either way I'm going oh wait
that's that's round trip though yeah
round trip you'll see is it round trip
hey click click on that uh have my magic
click on that 6 a.m. flight non-stop
this one here
yeah okay
yeah so you're not carrying on bag so
that's fine yeah that's another don't do
don't do 6 a.m. notp you can carry do
car on bags 38 or 99 bucks no do the 225
that gets in an 825 PM Spirit no
spirit's a bad idea because you'll pay
more for here we go that's
United either way is there any way your
family can meet you in Indianapolis
finding cheaper flights than let me see
if I can go on my uh let me see if I can
go on my Expedia and get you a better
price is that Google flights no it's
Expedia let me see how many points I got
yeah let me
see I don't think I'm gonna faint and
forget about this um change the go go go
select and see what it that's 400 bucks
each for him to see his family no Brian
got this it's totally fine no Brian's
got this I promise I'll cover Brandon
sponsorship from rain will pay for this
and this is where we want to go no for
real George if you want to go we'll make
it happen when we get off a we won't
have chin Google it so we can get it
done today but way by the way when the
cameras are off we're going to look at
George and go we were [__] kidding
I'm not paying you
[__] Panda gift card Let's uh Joy faton
B you're talking about doing facial work
here um our boy joy faton and sink's
coming out saying he does some stuff
every now and then yeah and give a
little bit of flack for it I'm surprised
you not know was Z I'm not doing it I'm
surprised you not that it was zic now do
me and him look very similar if I wasn't
carnivore yes you don't think we look
similar no man I feel like that's my
long lost brother no there's there my
body SL goes slowly morph into him if I
get off my diet and then Joey
Diaz dude we're like we look like three
family members around the than not
really you've been working out your
whole life so it's a little bit
different you don't think I look
anything like him when I was 270 I see
it you're you're no you're different
body type bua m they're better aren't
they a God so you got a cosmetic what
did he get like air
sculpting what's that I mean it's not as
invasive but I I from what I it's like
uh uh lipo in a sense or I think it's
more like a cool sculpting like machine
I those are waste of time freezes the
fat so apparently the the the concept is
it's supposed to freeze the fat cells
and the fat cells die so it kind it came
out a long time ago that's all fake I
thought the same thing it's all [__]
it's fake
I just think it's kind of nice my girl
had a fat friend who did it didn't work
oh god there don't say her name no I
won't trust me it should be for like
stubborn fat not for like a fat person
doesn't work my friend my girl has a fat
friend who did if she's if she's so if
she's like really fat no it doesn't work
you can't do anything it did nothing
matter of fact she got fatter she got
hungrier oh my God she got hunger it's
almost like that's not the it's almost
like you can't cure your obesity with
the cold no there's like
exercise no we we got a we got a we got
a staple your mouth shut oh my god well
it does come down to calories at the end
of the day yeah it does calories
calories in calories out is it more diet
or exercise diet yeah diet but you
should exercise you should exercise just
for to feel good but you could get away
with losing weight not touching weights
or entering a gym easily y That's
George's the diet Master over here he's
the one that was 700 lb 450 close enough
why do I think 700 400 you always like I
always it you always add a little bit
more rough 4 think about he was
450 ass got CU he got down to 200
something looks great you lifting
weights I've been slacking recently but
I need to get back into it I've been
lazy just 20 minutes yeah not not an
hour try 20 yes sir all diet isn't it
Georgie oh yeah diet
discipline even Thanksgiving you can you
can go carnivore just
Thanksgiving you look like a sociopath
you can do
it yeah I'm not uh convinced on the
carnivore stuff I need some I need some
carbs personally yeah you're skinny
though so I don't take advice from those
people I'm muscular don't say skinny it
makes me angry makes me mad though you
know so say say say muscular say
athletic no yeah you say athletic no say
it
nope never oh I don't care it hurts his
shitty boot it's not shitty don't say my
boots are shitty just bought him it's
called [__] it's from an Amsterdam
company okay Amsterdam yeah call my boot
shitty it's where I [__] draw the
line do this one go ahead this is
amazing people calling X kib I sent this
to the golden hour chat what's this this
is good just don't mess with these she
scared of me to every why her ass out I
think they're strippers it biblically
states that prostitution is a sin
but why didn't she pull up her pants and
you think
dancing in the middle of an argument you
don't think what you're doing andon go
ahead go ahead oh she has some
training this [__] is
crazy is this a VH1 reality show I think
Is This Love Hip Hop oh oh fight me but
hold on why is her ass out she's a
stripper arguing that prostitution is
against like her Christian values and
she's right she's hot hot yeah she's hot
and has a great double leg Jesus she she
must have wrestled in high school with
some she got down she cut the angle she
she R the I know this girl and her dad
is an insanely good Jiu Jitsu coach her
brother does MMA as well oh there you go
but but you were pick somebody who has
no idea how to fight great butt yeah but
yeah I
know her name is k I love hold on I
can't get over why are her pants
down she had more than time to pull her
[__] trunks doesn't have them on B
you talking about yeah but why is she
picking on a girl who doesn't know how
to fight like pick on somebody who can
fight boom that's not impressive and
then does she get to Mount with her
[__] she's she's very hot can I get
some more but that's being a bully
that's shitty you're picking on somebody
who has no idea I don't know I don't
know who's bully here I don't know
what's going on there all I can't
emphasize enough why are her pants down
cuz she was stripping and she's outside
and that's what I know but there's
enough time to pull them up
I still don't approve of that she was on
a break no don't go to hashtag I me I
didn't see her actual Instagram it's on
there which one right there this one yep
that's his sister Gia well
see no that's definitely not her he
probably has a mean double leg too oh
yeah let's go to the hashtags and we'll
probably find her from here what a
bummer I wish they didn't stop the video
though I want to see if she got to M
there she is is that her at top left
yeah yeah should be
no that's not her she's tooo she that
girl's prettier than the one with that's
her for sure the one on the
right she has small mouth and
nose oh this is some TV show is it
wilding out or some [__] wow that's
racist she's really pretty though wow
wow wow wow whiling out that Nick you
piece of [__] you old white [__] yeah I
don't know you shut up dude what is this
like wilding out or something hey dude
shut the [__] up have you ever seen
wilding out no
[__] just was this one of those bet
things oh my God shut up you young
bastards wild sorry that I'm [__] old
where's Matt R guy I
love what got J we can't find her so
awkward that she took her down like that
it's awkward her pants are down that's
kind of nice technique
great technique yeah not bad yeah you
watch football yesterday I really watch
Pro College go to mine my suck college
football one I sent you your bronos
yesterday Broncos foure
[__] your boy uh I want him to lose
though so we get a good pick what are we
doing what this ad breaks silence over
social media's users shock reactions we
can do yeah we'll do this one first so
ad Lima um got some work done guys she's
a super model uh
oh still
super that's her right there uh but wait
wait is she on the left or right that's
her but which one's current her that's
yeah I don't like how they put the left
as the new she's getting older so she
got her she got her face tight she got
fillers she got whatever Joey Fon got
yeah it's like I'm gonna when I when I
show up and I look like her everybody's
gonna be like oh Brian got work done and
it's not fair it's funny how time does
its thing though time do she's still
pretty and she had a too so that changed
you yeah her eyebrows are sharp as [__]
still get that bodyx when she was
younger she was so impossibly hot oh
yeah and she's just getting older okay I
know I mean it is what it is what but
that's her I think should be mean that's
her with no makeup she looks better the
face of a tired mom of one teenage girl
two pre-teens one active boy that's a
hot woman oneye old I any so she has one
three four she has five kids that's a
lot man and she looks great so everybody
shut up I think she looks great and I
love that you two boys agree with that
that's what yeah and this is without
make this is scumbag internet people by
the way it's mostly women who are just
hating on her and they love it and it's
just like get a life you [__] Donuts
okay so I I don't know if you guys watch
this game Florida State University their
quarterback got a little banged up this
weekend so out right he got hurt yeah
just watch the
clip he's a stud too BR watch his
ankle oh I hate that [__] oh [__] you
well FSU is not going to be in the top
four no no no yeah he's confirmed
out yeah you can't put him you can't put
floor in top four without their Star
Quarterback was that was that his uh
that's not a bone that's his ankle or
something that's his knee I don't know
what it is it looked like an ankle high
ankle no but watch watch dude look his
his entire leg is switched over that's
like everything's a night yeah
everything's is that the end of his
[__] career or what no not with
technology and science these days but
that's the end of the season in and
that's the end of the and FSU is
undefeated yeah
put's out too yeah his wrist is brok he
couldn't even grip a
ball said he heard a pop or something
the the year of the Browns and wow do
you see that brown Steelers game yeah
you're the Browns that's what your wife
says over here oh my God what' you say
hey dude the one thing I will not
take
is saying that kind of
stuff and my boot you're the
Browns you're the Browns is outrageous
now it might be a little bit true but
still G yeah that's tough that's just
hate to see it that's a gross one see it
so this one I think is so frustrating
and crazy so um this girl was out hiking
and saw these Bears that's a Mama Bear
oh brown bear with Cubs oh no so let me
show you see this is this is scary thick
bear so these are the
new MRE
[Music]
MRE so she's roaring which is good is it
yeah she's supposed to like standall run
say please get everyone that says says
thate Get out no run no you don't run
you do not run just keep stepping back
stand and do this just keep yell it's
got It's got it baby keep doing that
stupid Roar and just back up all all
it's doing is protecting his baby so
just get away from the baby [__] yeah
just back ways
slowly oh that stupid whistle ain't
helping I thought if it's brown laid
down if it's black fight back remember
we we we talk about this before I okay
it is I'm talking about bears a little
racist some people can hear that take
you the wrong way you yeah that's
exactly bear spray bear spray or a gun
that that's all you should have is she
okay well she don't have either no she
survived also don't be running out there
so this is frustrating but then I'll
show you this clip there's a guy that's
on the trail with her and this is what
happens look at
this so you just go towards them so Dum
yeah idiot yeah okay dude
idiots now I you go towards them he's
like I got this baby I go very far away
from them this seems like a first where
is this by the
way she's probably hot and he was like
you know what it's worth kind of let me
see if I can protect her from a to see
her you're absolutely right let's see
let's see if we would this is her oh she
has dreads I'm out I'm not at all
handful nope if a white girl has dreads
if a white girl has dreads that is a red
flag and they shouldn't be allowed to
vote were they dreads or were they
braids Jen I'm a fan of dreads I know a
white person with dreads is the biggest
red flag in the world probably true but
those are mean she talks with her hands
those are braids those aren't dreads
those are braids and I'm a fan unless
you came back from Mexico you can't rock
that can you go back uh go back see that
no with the with that outfit on that
that outfit the I want to make sure I'm
doing research which one the [__]
yellow outfit right there CH you got to
tell me which outfit don't say just
outfit there you go no we see samurai
sword dude why didn't she have that when
she was you know that's a good point
yogging um there you go yeah she's a she
looks like she's a love Latin descent or
something she's got that her name's
Laura gold oh she's Jewish then yes
partially or fully whatever I I'm a fan
Samurai SW right there I'm a fanal
Kombat she's looking for a sword fight a
fan ah I don't know man so homeboy uh
was like I'm Gonna Save this girl that's
what he did and he walked towards the
bear and there's a footage of him like
walking the bear sort of yeah that was
the first days trying to get his dick
suck dude dude he's thinking with with
his dick not with his brain I get eaten
ass first but you know what worth worth
cuz if I do survive give my dick suck
yeah let me walk you down I survived
this let me give my dick how do you guys
mean he protected me in the wilderness
from a Grizzly oh were they attack you
no he followed him harassed these
Grizzly Oh weird how come he doesn't
have SS he could have avoided it why
doesn't he have a any a leg anymore oh
um he doesn't hike with me
anymore all righty um
when when's the next next time you guys
are going to fly uh all the time so go
ahead de December 7th I'm going to
Indiana okay so I don't know if you guys
know knew this I didn't know this so if
you're sitting on the aisle seat of the
plane there's a button you can push to
lift that little arm up no did you know
that or not no I've tried this there's
the little arm between everybody no no
if you're in the aisle you know there's
like the window the middle and then the
aisle I I like to sit in the aisle cuz I
want to go to the bathroom you know me
the armrest doesn't like lift up but
apparently this flight attendant says
there's like a hidden button that's cool
you can use so CH I've tried okay I'll
show you right now GE will you tell us
after your flight I like the
armrest now I don't know if this applies
to Spirit Airlines if you want to leave
like if you like say you're leaving to
go back you know to go outside of the
airplane like you want to like have some
what you're saying man in on the Isis
seat wondering why your armrest doesn't
go up well here you go here's a little
hack for you press this little hidden
button yeah that's never that's a new
plane though is it I don't know no aand
newe it's a law are you say it's a law
yes you have to have that for um fat
Escape uh I've I've looked at the
manual fatty you made that
up break silence on rumors about his
sexuality he's
gay yeah
so after his friend of like if he says
anything like it's none of your business
or that's what I do in the bedroom is my
business you get
which is all good baby what's he say
here he said the same thing that Jada
said like it's obviously false
unequivocally false but yeah I wouldn't
even I'd be
like I mean this is how i' i' address
that if you know you're straight
somebody says that I would just go
here's my
answer and then just oh wow see that's
gay no here's my answer oh wow this how
let me try again here's my answer ask me
you gay bro ask me about the rumors you
know there's some rumors that you sucked
off some black guys in
Calgary really here's what I have to say
about
that yeah that's you know what I mean
and we go now you know now you know that
I didn't thank you from for confirming
this rumor yeah but the rumor like this
what it must have got so bad he had to
say something the rumor is so crazy cuz
remember the guy that said that he was
with him for like 40 years as his
assistant whatever I don't bu me like
murdering him he said murdering that ass
he's obviously they're ex-friends and a
guy who's been with him for that long to
me and you go bad on him you are this is
a vend it says more about that guy than
Will Smith anytime a actual friend goes
bad on someone it says more about that
person the person they're talking about
I think he I think that guy sucks and
he's not he's not a man cuz he fights
it's never anybody doing here's the
thing though no he fights like a [__]
he's not a man let's say it's true
though let's say it's true he shouldn't
be talking about it
and if it's true you saw it then just
keep it to yourself murdering
that bent over and murdering him
hilarious character assassination makes
it a little tough it's just you know a
little tough betrayal you know betrayal
it's not the way to do it if you don't
like will you should do it a different
way all right so this is uh Bill Burr
talking to Rich Eisen I believe about
the whole like controversy where Bill
Burr's wife was flipping off on camera
when uh Donald Trump was walking down I
love Bill Bert my thing if my my wife
did this I'm like hey left and right buy
tickets we don't care who buys them we
like both we're not picking a side
that's all that's why I'd be upset you
cut my FAS in
half uh or or or it's his wife and I
love my wife you know where you you know
where you stand with her the guy walked
in the arena everybody cheered she gave
him the finger nobody got arrested
that's why this country is great
everybody expressed themselves can we
all be adults I don't know about you but
I came here to see the fights I didn't
know I was going to to a Republican naal
convention it's fine
fine yeah you're allowed to give you're
allowed to give your leader the strength
of our country is you're allowed to give
any leader the finger you're allowed to
say [__] off and that's that's what's
great about try it in Russia North Korea
though correct see what goly do it in
Ukraine right now that's
right uh do you guys want a sports one
or a politics one uh I want
both okay so feeling cheeky let's do the
sports one
first was do it that's just taking a big
breath okay uh I thought this was
cool if this loads J's not a big Sports
guy so this worries me what so this DK
medf and his
opponent but the computer's running a
little bit slowly yeah this one's sweet
has DK mattf giv him the guy a jersey
cuz son big fan so he takes his jersey
off his OPP said like my son's a big fan
of yours he's 15 years old he looks up
to you he looks like your size and this
and that so mchf took off his jersey and
signed it's sweet cuz he says I don't
know if this matters to you or like I
don't know if it's a big deal to you
built just like you that kid must be
a my son big man just like you bro keep
doing your thing you can get
this hold on your son's 15's built like
DK M say bet he say I was going to say
that's I don't think eats once he eats
once a day DJ metf what today GJ ma is
such a
freak that's sweet though 64 235
something everybody shows up on your
algorithm huh play boy well that that
guy that's a super athlete 64 235 hey
show up Al I know what you're talking
about dude can I get more DJ man what's
his Instagram he's a freak he's a freak
he eats once a day once a day yeah he
only eats once a day it's amazing that's
a whole different thing he loves gummies
candies gummies wow does he m do you
know much about this Bri or no um I know
that he used to be a rock star and I
know that Argentina had has had major
problems with their curreny yeah so but
it worked out for Ukraine because they
picked zinski and he was a comedian that
played the piano with his wiener so that
worked out yep but this guy apparently
so his name is Javier mle so he got
elected as president for Argentina which
is kind of crazy I guess he's considered
like the Donald Trump of here and he got
elected and
a Libertarian do you guys know what a
Libertarian
is so when you say libertarian do you
understand what that is just just so
everybody I thought that's left right no
it's not to be middle a Libertarian is
is a Libertarian is is a Libertarian
essentially believes that small
government is the answer the state
should not be involved in almost
anything except for Defense building
roads and even that a little opposite of
trump well Trump is what it's called a
republican Republicans typic
Are For Less government intervention in
business right so lower taxes and things
like that the right stuff small small
business empowerment and stuff like that
you America first now Republicans in
this country have a lot of other things
going on there's not a big difference in
between Democrats and Republicans in
this iteration but the stand was that
yeah but the idea is that Libertarians
do not believe you can socially engineer
equality Libertarians believe that the
marketplace and the free market should
rule the roost and that did you know
that chin and government should be a
necessary before you bring this [__] up
I'm I don't know [__] about anything if
anything tell us what you think about
this guy though put me tole should be
consider what do you think of this guy
though they would a lot of I'll show you
some clips though lot people call
Libertarians far right in many ways
because they are they are for very small
government I have anybody's far right
that's not on the left that's what the
left that's right I there are a lot of
things about the libertarian platform
that I support because I think
government gets very big there's no
accountability you're a Libertarian so
they're saying he's like the Real a true
libertarian yeah if you believe in gay
marriage for example you don't believe
the government should be involved in the
marriage business that's a Libertarian
position you know if you uh there's a
lot of things that go on like that so
let me play you this clip real quick oh
yeah we're still doing it
okay almost all tend to be second
amendment Pro Second
Amendment Free Speech M you know what
maybe it's not meant to be cuz a damn Bo
God damn it now and that's the new
computer CH now in Argentina this is the
new computer this is my laptop that's my
new computer yeah but anyways this guy's
like left hard
son his hair's
[Applause]
insane oh
wow he got
eled
so can just stop for a second you know
what an anarco capitalist is aarco
capitalist Anarchy and capitalist so the
idea is government stays the [__] out of
the marketplace they tend to be a lot of
people that are really into crypto they
don't want to be Holden to a dollar that
can be tracked so they would be called
anarch anarat criminals now this guy's
very dramatic he was a performer he's
very very dramatic at his hair of course
but he's so sick of and a lot of
argentinians are so sick of how badly
the government [__] up
the economy and it's been going on since
really the 90s I mean they they had they
had an economic collapse in the real
sense the word the yeah so he's going
downhill and now he's actually elected
he's president now well you know what
things are looking
up so he's very happy with his hair I
think my brother sent me this he's like
hopefully this is a good sign for like
us as well like the rest of the
countries out here you know what I'm
saying if this we don't take leads from
Argentina no but this is a good sign
though
this is um is it yes to let dude less
government control this is um if if the
other video worked it would show you
some other cool [__] my guess though is
yeah let's
see here we
go a Sideburn so basically everything
that the government controls like get
out of
here who represents that though here
America's a little different can I
go ahead
BR he's saying basically all these
different Ministries get in there yeah
well all these Ministries had to be out
of here okay so there were a lot of
people in the who a lot of Libertarians
who were on on the Trump team who also
believed this they came in they they
came into the department of energy and
they were walking around going what is
this [__] Department of energy well
let's hold on they all the department
energy is full of full of nuclear
physicists and scientists A who who keep
track of the uranium in the world who
keep track of all the spent uranium rods
and CAT scans and the machines
diagnostic machines if you detonated a
spent uranium Rod the size of a pencil
over let's say uh the Super Bowl it's a
dirty bomb you have to evacuate that
town for 20 years um the department also
provided provided all the low interest
uh loans that Tesla built their company
on um you know so Department of energy
does a whole bunch of stuff at the
Department of Agriculture yeah the
department keep all the birds out of the
Airfield when you fly yep you want to
run the birds on your [__] SP
scientists that are figuring out how to
get sheep to graze at higher this
because of global warming warming so
well let's when you buy a house okay and
you buy the materials for the house
who's it come from guess what you know
that the the stuff you're using the
materials you're using are not toxic and
don't give off certain gases that can
kill your children you know why because
we have a department of we have we have
an agency like I think it's the
Department of Commerce that makes sure
of that when you drink your water out of
your tap the reason the people that that
that are responsible for managing the
electric grid those are government
bureaucrats so when you start to see how
much how much your tax dollars actually
do and and the kind of things that we
all rely on when it tune you sing a
different tune so these people like that
he doesn't have government he's he's a
rockstar who came in and he's a he's a
populist so he's like we're getting rid
of this we're getting rid of this he's
not going to be able to do that it's
theatric get he's being theatrical now
did you see our sitting president see a
six-year-old in the stands and was like
you're beautiful what are you 14 and
some girl goes no she's six and he goes
I love your ears so we're doing just
fine here just fine just fine you know
and and uh as far as like scientific
research the internet the internet
everybody GPS
everybody those came out of the
Department of Defense those came out of
so so cuz a lot of times research you
for is too expensive
for private companies to finance because
they it's a 20 year 30 year 40-year
payoff that's why these these the DARPA
arpa these different things are are the
ones that that that provide low interest
loans and and universities they they
finance universities and different
scientists to do these long-term studies
that's what that's where your [__]
tax dollars go chin people should
educate themselves a little bit as
somebody who believes in small
government yes well it doesn't sound
like it but yes there's a good book
called The Fifth risk about read that
after this you know what read a few
pages on read a few pages for the
fans any other hold on fuing questions
if this guy is the new Trump right he's
not the he's not Trump well we don't
know yet he they're saying he's Trump
cuz he's loud and he says he's a very
he's a very theatrical populist you know
what a populist is no I don't know tell
him so see chin I need you to get I need
get you this book that's why that's why
I ask you question popul do it on your
own time
you say he's a populist candidate chin
tell them whatp that means that means
that that popular he's popular people so
he is a direct mouthpiece to the people
so so a populist would say the [__]
government is [__] and you guys got you
the little man has to have a say you're
speaking for the average person The Rock
The Rock ised it's expedient it's noted
we have a very refined democracy fine I
got you we have we have congressmen who
are elected any other questions just let
me ask you one one more question yeah
please keep going do you guys think
Trump did better or Biden did better
country oh I I I mean do we have four
hours just a quick answer yes or no not
Trum Trump I I don't like either them
but as far as straight up politics and
policies Trump compared to Biden
gotcha depends on the
issue overall Bri overall you need that
middle of the road K here You' um I
don't like Biden at all and I think
Biden's been
hijacked huge problems with the
Democratic party huge problems wait um
chin you've got to start to you go ahead
got to get you got get I know nothing
about politics I'll tell you now no
unfortunately you don't know a lot about
certain a lot of things and what do you
mean a lot of things well basic thing
when did World War II
end I don't know history like
that wait let's ask the entire crew here
you know what years it was hold on let's
ask the entire crew ask Brennan ask S
ask Georgie I'm always depressed when I
see how little people I know they don't
know either I know no I know World War
II when did it end uh let's see it
dropped with the bomb so probably at
what 45 correct suck my dick CH I read
do you know what cities in Japan were
decimated by nuclear bombs you should
know this why Hiroshima everybody come
on I'm Korean dog oh my God why do you
have to make it about race it's
unbelievable wait Brian wants to take a
cold old hand to your face right now
Arch D FR wait wait okay Bren who was
World War II ask this when was the
Korean War Korean War and the Vietnam
War well Vietnam War was 68 to 70 what
it's actually started earlier than that
but you could say 68 was the T offens 68
when got bad but 74 is when it ended
74 was it when wasen War
1952 I could have sworn it was in the
40s no no no way to go chin CH I this
proves our point I need you to even the
Korean [__] you got wrong 1950 yeah well
52 okay so me and you are close enough
then no I said 40s you said 52 that
means not anywhere near me when it comes
to knowledge about if it's 40s no it
could be 48 49 it's a longer it's a
longer take L conversation but the the
raid the the the the the Korean war in
its sort of J you know who World War II
who was on what side World War II yep no
yeah I remember remembering this a long
time ago but I just lost it the reason
that you have to you you here's the
thing you might just be interested in it
you probably learned I learned obviously
I graduated high school it's directly
related to why the world you're living
in today in a lot of ways that's going
deep what do you mean Brian you know it
just I and see I trying I was trying to
avoid politics but here we
are yes but I mean just remembering the
dates I that's what what happened I'm
always amazed at how how most people are
just like like I asked these questions
like what what continent is Egypt in
Africa Africa
yeah they all just learned that Brian oh
come on
dude all right you didn't shout it very
fast Africa eretrian people are from
Africa we knew this because of arrian
rare TR are are are Muslim or Christian
Christian Christian
I didn't know what do they what do they
border and what war do they fight what
oh my
God Ethiopia but but listen um it's just
important I think to be a little bit
aware of the world around you and I I
think that's that's to everyone's and I
understand CH because we can get cool
you can't make a song about it no we can
get through life without it you know so
it's not doesn't affect your day-to-day
so I understand why you're you're not
nobody nobody's really exposed you to it
so I'm not I hate when people I'm not
shaming you we're not bashing you for
being stupid because because there's a
lot of shame to R like oh I don't know
this it's just we're not doing that no
we would never it's just information no
just stupid that's it's history but I
mean he just went to public school it's
not a big deal I mean it's just
information yeah all right but but just
acknowledge and you do that you know
there's probably some things you
probably some holes in your just acknow
in your knowledge that you could fill
that's why we need to wrap this showled
as far as history you have holes yeah I
don't know the details about I learned
them a long ass time ago I forgot about
by the even like States like even going
to the the map how many states you think
could know if I gave you a blank map it
would be it would be tough for me I
think you get can you name can you name
uh five countries five
countries besides besides Korea and
America can you name three countries in
Europe in Europe yeah no big deal I just
want to see England George England yeah
um you've been to some of these places
Australia that's not that's not Europe
that's not Europe that's not Europe
that's not Europe Ireland holy [__] okay
that works Germany Italy think about hey
they're asking me think about what's
around uh Ireland but I even told you
guys I suck at this stuff like I I
remember learning this and passing the
test but I forgot the only reason I
would say it's important to learn sh is
because we're going to go to become a
tool you become a tool for forces much
greater than yourself
and they will use you as a tool right so
that you don't remember the country yes
CH because what he say you had a point
of view right and it's not your they're
going to H you like a I'm using you chin
as a as a as a just as a an example not
because it's it's relevant listening
he's not picking on you so you had you
had you had a point of
view less government that was your point
of view right you said it's probably a
good thing my brother literally just
show me this article about this guy so I
want to ask you about [__] up hold on
I'll take you from here you did less
government it's just important to know
why that's all it's important to know
why build a foundation it's really easy
it's so easy people think oh educ I
could I can give you a [__] reading
list in in a year you'd be like you get
it done in six years easy so much well
it would spark an interest to learn more
your want to learn more you don't you
get 70 Summers 75 75 see I remember that
you're a giant Asian you have 70 yeah
it's okay I suppos get more we we can
ran has 10 more Summers I I'm not trying
to play a gachi game got I'm super
honest like I dude I suck at directions
I have a zero understanding of
directions like like my my sense of
direction is horrible that's way you're
Bor I don't remember I don't remember
the countries I don't remember like the
all this stuff I build skill sets in
different areas that I know you're very
good at your job I'll yeah what that's
why I'm like I'm good guitar you're bad
at good at guitar you're very good at
you're talented you're really good at
music you're really good at your job
you're [__] disciplined this [__] say
and the truth is the truth is it'd be
like what I just asked you a bunch of
questions would be like somebody asked
me about sports I don't know Sports so
it's the same thing so it's just it
doesn't mean you're dumb it doesn't mean
anything it just means you're just not
interested in that because it doesn't
life you like you like guitar right you
like guitar you like Tim mcgr and you
like big tits yeah that's America you
piece of [__] guitar what art he's good
at music he's got a lot of great talents
he's a great person and I respect you I
I respect you a great deal I respect
your toughness I respect your discipline
must consistency you had a mustache
before we did yep I did I think you're a
great person and it's just a classic
example of how smart how a smart you
stick up to Brian person just as that
has big gaps like we all do we all have
that what I just did to you you could do
to me andow a lot of subjects fight
let's go through that fighting no I know
fighting Sports remember me remember me
fighting Sports remember me with sports
when football with football sports he
took me he took me to the Football Hall
of Fame and I was like remember they
were asking me about about oh my God I I
did a job for NL and I got Bri in there
and they're like tell us what you think
of D oh my god dude he was like you know
his arm with the Bangles unheard of no
this is the Hall of Fame I was like well
d p Manning didn't have any good
receivers and I I went hold on let me
talk hold on hold Marvin Harrison dude
everything is like that you went to the
NFL Hall of Fame yeah what city was it
in um K Connecticut K Ohio don't tell
him was it were we in Ohio Ohio don't
even remember where it was we're playing
Columbus I the NFL Network you don't
even remember where it was no but again
see see how stupid he looks real quick
let me ask you a question BR how many
countries are there in Latin America oh
you got him Ro i' have to count them
stupid Brian stupid [__] idiot just
give me like minimum Argentina Chile
Uruguay Paraguay um brail good Peru I
mean uh we have uh in sou in South
America alone smart Latin America Latin
America so you've got Panama Costa Rica
El Salvador Nicaragua you've got um any
other questions CH you're not going to
win that war you got a few of them
though yeah when it comes to naming
countries colia columia Venezuela
Ecuador Ecuador yeah I can name them all
dude you know I senior future I'm the
wrong guy to ask about that stuff gey
you but that's not again I don't care
about that I think it's good to expose
yourself to ideas though right yeah but
phos dates and countries I I think like
for the world war for the war stuff you
well you don't have kids I remember he
you know what yeah what D
doesn't you don't have kids right cuz my
I have kids and they'll ask these
questions and I mean could Google and be
a but also about when you have kids you
care more about the world and those
Trends you start to say why is this the
world moving in this direction what's
why why is child learn they had a JFK
special on the other day and he's like
Daddy what you know who's that explained
to him I was like he was killed and he
was like oh one guy killed him I was
like no no do you want to go down this
road with your dad cuz and get hairy
can't get hairy so we spent an hour
covering some conspiracy you know what I
think I I'll ended this bad ideas there
are bad ideas there are good ideas part
of like your educ learning how the
reason you want to be educated is to
learn what to care about and what not to
care about and to learn what a bad idea
is and what a good idea is if you don't
you can that that way lies hell if if
you if you get seduced by bad ideas and
people who are very seductive who pedal
bad ideas you get What's called the Nazi
Revolution the Communist Revolution etc
etc so that's going on right now similar
people are on they're uneducated about
what happened with the Nazis and the
Jews so you see anti-Semitism up right
now they don't realize this is exactly
how it happened over in Germany
they make them l l it's less and you
start seeing the marketing and all of a
sudden you know on the algorithm on Tik
Tok and Twitter and all that [__] and
then all of SE all of a sudden you know
you think it's okay to to shame Jews
some somehow becomes the norm and then
they become not human well you go like
this you go wait they own a lot of stuff
they must be part of the they must be
the problem and that is a conversation
going on and that's exactly what
happened in Germany in the 1940s they
owned all the businesses and they're in
a recession so they went well look
they're
doing take it from them art technology
the economy banking theyve dominated
everything as long as they've been on
Earth they dominate they take over
things because they're very there's a
reason for that there 15 million Jews in
in the world in the world more Jews in I
believe New York or in the United States
than there are in Israel so so their
history has been one of you know that's
why they don't play this [__] like when
Kanye did that that's why they're like
nope cuz they know the road this goes
down
and sure enough it's happening well
anti-Semitism has always been on the
surface it's always waiting to come out
people just you know they know that but
to your point to your point that that's
right so people die when the when bad
ideas gain hold people die Hamas is a
bad idea to correct that Bri to correct
that bad ideas gain traction because
dumb people the uneducated people don't
realize it's a bad idea there you go and
so they rally around it they don't they
don't realize how bad it's going to get
that's right that's a so [__] true
and you know what the biggest threat is
that your algorithm like you can watch
people get their information from Tik
Tok now a lot of young people and that's
own by the Chinese so I'm sure there's
no misinformation there but uh young
people learn that and the problem is
it's not so much ignorance it's when you
think you know something that is not
true it's the knowing it is the doubling
down and I've got the truth and you're
you've been you've been you've been
[__] fooled down a rabbit hole and
there's no Truth at the end of that
rabbit hole and there are enough people
like that that can get some [__] going
that's why Brian saying it's dangerous
to be uneducated about these things cuz
then it makes it that much easier for
them to pull you over under the dark if
you don't remember the history you're
it'll repeat itself and and this because
it's always there that's all so as as
you're the reason the world's the [__]
show is what I'm trying but as far as
remembering like countries and cities
and you know all no no I'm saying like
if you're if you don't know those things
and then you're like you know
passionately I'm going to I'm going to
be on this side I'm not that I'm just
like I just don't remember the fre know
I said that's that's why that's why I'm
using as an example I I mean you're uh
you know how I feel about you I love
yeah of course I know so so so it's but
but I like to use you as an you're
somebody I really care not a huge deal
no but it's good that you're you're also
like you don't have an ego on this
you're I'm being open and honest yeah
like and I wish I could admit I was
stupid what the [__] well you got
interested in it I remember you you got
his moment I was having a conversation
with some people about history and about
this stuff and that dinner with you Bren
was like I don't [__] have anything
to say here cuz he hadn't studied it he
didn't know football but the difference
between me and Chin I'm I'm super like
we grandp we studied in early nais I got
and I saw the history then I just
anything World War II your boys balls
deep in it you also got very very
political about you saw what happens
when unaccountable bureaucrats can
control an economy shut down eom and you
this
is and you see the health ministers
bring up the health Ministers of new we
saw this before Bri yeah that that was
incredible ter and you go wait these are
the people who are keeping us healthy
huh interesting of where New
Zealand Health Ministers of the World
meme that's pretty funny new Zeal it's
also different when you have kids to
they're going ask you a bunch of [__]
Min if they always see you reaching for
your phone to Google it you just seem
like a dumb then they don't respect you
you want to know a little bit about
everything yeah there you go that that
woman right there that's Maggie de block
she's a the one looks look like a Bergen
from the trolls oh my go look bring up
bring up the the prince for the trolls
one movie The Bergen it's
identical you're so good at this trolls
Prince oh my boom I'm too good at this
man very good same person that's
impressive same person that's pretty
tough wait so do you guys remember
everything from grade school no no I
think they continue to study yeah
education is one of those things right
you read a book you forget most of it
right and you you justang we'll talk
we'll talk I can give you but it's like
you started with my obsession with JFK
and they're like how do get assassin
name they're like what was it what were
the reasons they want why would they
want to Assassin name then you go into
the B you got into it recently though no
I mean years dude think how long we've
been doing the show years yeah I mean
but not like since you school no it's
all sport there are some things that are
worth spending your time on other things
are not worth spending your time on
right there there's a good path there's
a bad path right and I think come from a
guy that spends two hours a day studying
black [__] yeah at least at least and
but he still finds time to do this other
no I'm just really curious like so you
guys study this every day you just want
to you just want to be moving in the
direction probably and I think you do
I'm not saying you don't I I'm talking
to people I don't you want to be moving
in the direction of of of where where
the the truth can be found what what are
the ideas worth investing in and pushing
that'll make the world stuff you're
interested in J if you're noted
it's not going to it's going to take but
if you're like if you're interested in
the Korean War we see why it was the
Korean and it's going to lead you down
this path then you're going to be
interested in the other stuff this is
also American because Americans are not
affected by history the way Europeans
are or the way a dastani would be or the
way so when you when you go to Russia
you they they don't have a choice but
they live history history they usually
are on the losing end of History okay
most as America yeah yeah undefeated
yeah it's true but when you're when
you're when you're friend
have history you can you see it in the
architecture you see it in your culture
you see it because you're mixing with so
many different countries and so so
that's why most Europeans speak two
other languages because they of the
proximity that they speaks too yeah I
speak one really bad or I speak three
but one badly what do we speak Spanish
too damn damn K see and I don't so you
speak those but I mean not great though
but yeah hey it's still better than most
but point it's not relevant why would
you do it right now cu no also think you
know like Joe Rogan says like you put so
much data into your head and then you
can only store so much I have so much
stuff in my head tits music tits music
tits too I I forgot about I remember
doing all the countries passing all the
tests and doing all you know whatever
it's just it's just gone I don't care
let me ask everybody in the room
something this is a cool question
somebody asked what do you do you think
there's a primary question you ask
yourself every day is there is there a
question that's always running through
your head every day what is the primary
they say most of us as human beings
psychologically have what's called a
primary question and the question's not
a good one it's typically it's not an
emping question yeah like am I lovable
what if I fail who you know you ever
want yeah it's a really it's a profound
question right because most of the
questions we ask are shitty questions
with shitty answers and what a lot of
people will tell you is to change that
primary question in your mind they'll
tell you to actually change the question
those people all rich and happy what
action do I have to take today to get
close from a successful guy though it's
like you weren't doing that [__] when
you're coming up right those people
they're at the top they're like ask
yourself like [__] I'm trying to pay
the bills yeah but you can change your
mind dick jokes off to pay for this the
rods and this Ford Lightning piece of
[__] oh wait let's get to your Ford n
it's over oh the video oh my God cuz you
don't buy a car interet it turns out
your your now your Ford I think is is UN
because you drove it here I saw it your
your Ford is your Ford is probably UNS
salvageable no no no oh it's not no I'll
figure it out you will yeah 100% but you
took it and they said hey well cuz Ford
can't because a it's an older model and
B it's modified so you got to get a you
got to take I got a specialist I get
this guy you get a different truck a
different like no no no I get this guy
Eddie at a addiction Motorsport who's
right up the street who's a mad
scientist with Lightnings oh so all he
needs to do is mess with the PCU the
computer and just get it lined up and it
should be okay now once he gets a hold
of he's like hey the transmission all
this then it's a different story so I
find out on Tuesday CU you get a new
transmission basically a new engine huh
you might have to take the engine out it
wouldn't be the engine it might be the
transmission could be the torque
converter could be the cats we're going
to find out on Tuesday now if he's like
but this thing's toasted then it's a
lemon we're going to have some problems
yeah but that's part of the fun this
made me laugh cuz you're you're you're
turning like a negative and a positive
because you know what you said Brenan
you know what you said when you found
out your truck was a lemon good good yep
that's how it goes dude you know what
you look uh look skinnier it's one keep
saying
yeah thanks dude but then when people
meet you they go I don't know you're so
big yeah I get that all the
time all right is that it uh unless you
want more no I
don't more I got to get going no I
actually got to go run the lightning
somewhere right now all right I'm in
Chicago keep on trucking tour Georgie
will be there that is December 8th and
9th two shows Friday two shows Saturday
and then the keep on trucking tour for
2024 kicks off in Nashville January 25th
one show only one night only in
Nashville then that Friday and Saturday
that's the 26th 27th I'm in Austin Texas
it's my birthday dude come on I know
take us at thick boy.com we just
released uh brand new similar to the
Colorado Rockies jerseys hoodies on
thick boy.com and we have our Black
Friday sale 40% off and that goes till
Cyber Monday just start today thick
boy.com get you some Chicago see you
December 8th and 9th all right listen uh
shout out to yuck Yu at Calgary thanks
for coming out guys it was amazing
indianap Indianapolis Indiana Indiana
helium December 7 89 Brian doing a
Thursday interesting uh yeah
Indianapolis helium December 7 8 and N
spaan Washington December 15 and 16 Baba
you have Thursdays on every single show
and off the hook uh off the hook you got
to do Thursday oh maybe I was supposed
to do Sunday but it's uh i' rather do a
Thursday than Sunday Florida off the
hook Comedy Club Captain Bri 21 22 23
yeah then I got Comedy Zone December 28
29331 wow uh December no I can't do
December 28th 293 31 that would be
Friday Saturday Sunday figure that is
yeah you'll figure it all out all right
kids love you guys we'll see you uh next
time we're out